croyez en votre pays faites qu'au moment
alors moi je suis née à fonbony
depuis toute petite j'ai toujours rêvé
de devenir journaliste et qu'on vous
savez pour réaliser ses rêves c'est très
difficile je m'appelle nourrina j'ai 22
ans je suis née et j'ai grandi au
Comores j'ai fait mon primaire le
collège et le lycée à moely jusqu'à
l'obtention de mon bac où il a fallu que
j'aille à l'étranger pour poursuivre mes
études supérieures j'ai fait le choix de
rester au Comores j'avais plusieurs
raisons la première était celle de
rester auprès de ma famille j'ai quand
même quitté ma famille parce que je suis
venu à mon Rony pour mes études quand je
suis arrivée j'ai fait deux années de
lettres modernes françaises à
l'Université des Comores ensuite on m'a
parlé d'une formation qui a été initié
par l'Ambassade de France en
collaboration avec l'Université des
Comores où j'ai suivi une formation en
communication journaliste
malheureusement cette formation n'existe
plus
j'ai eu la chance d'être parmi les
derniers qui ont bénéficié de cette
formation
aujourd'hui je suis journaliste et je
collabore également avec l'agence de
communication partie ma carrière a
débuté en juin 2019 quand j'ai intégré
l'agence de communication Darty où je
suis présentatrice de plusieurs
émissions à l'exemple d'archives des
Comores puis en août 2020 j'ai intégré à
loi toile via un concours
abonne c'est le premier journal du pays
où j'écris des articles dans le domaine
de la santé et la justice et je présente
également la revue de presse tous les
matins je vous parle en tant qu'une
fille comorienne une fille qui a grandi
aux Comores une fille qui a étudié au
Comores une fille qui travaille au
Comores une fille qui croit aux
opportunités que que nous offre ce pays
j'ai confiance en mon pays et j'ai la
confiance des gens pour qui je travaille
j'ai choisi de privilégier ma carrière
en voulant gagner de l'expérience donc
je suis resté à Moroni après l'obtention
de mon diplôme j'avais le choix de
partir travailler à mon lit mais j'ai
pris une grande décision de rester
amoureux c'était une décision qui qui
était très difficile pour moi le fait
d'être loin de ma famille mais également
pour ma famille de laisser leur jeune
fille non mariée à Moroni ça fait trois
ans que je vis cette belle aventure à
partie de la boîte one je la base tous
les jours pour attendre mes objectifs
quand j'écris la sage décision de rester
sur Moroni j'ai commencé à assembler les
pièces de mon puzzle et de faire mon
petit bout de parcours
aujourd'hui j'affronte mes galères parce
que c'est impossible d'y échapper et je
ne le regrette surtout pas je m'adresse
à tous les jeunes comme moi qui veulent
vivre une belle expérience
professionnelle qui ont peur de se
lancer qui pensent que pour avoir une
belle carrière font partie à l'étranger
ou faire une grande école ce n'est pas
forcément le cas quand vous voulez vous
pouvez même en restant aux Comores
certains jeunes pensent qu'après
l'Université des Comores les choses sont
minces
croyez en vous faites vous confiance et
faites ce que vous ayez aujourd'hui j'ai
fait mon bout de chemin avec mon travail
j'y retourne à Moïse quand l'occasion se
présente pour visiter ma famille je
n'oublie pas mes obligations familiales
ni le fait que je sois une jeune fille
comme rien
j'aspire à des objectifs plus grands et
je continue à écrire mon histoire